good morning good morning good morning
everybody happy thursday on what is it
october six great to be here again for
another gratitude journal live stream
number 19 it's awesome to have everybody
here in the house once again guys we are
doing this as a consistent thing it's
every day which one gratitude for the
things that we have in our life it makes
us happier and healthier entrepreneurs
and if you want to go out and have a
major impact we need entrepreneurs who
are out doing their things and so every
day you could join me every day you
could do it on your own just make sure
it's part of what you do every single
day I've seen tremendous impact on my
life and hopefully can bring that to
yours as well we do it here at nine a.m.
eastern I'm going to share three things
I'm going before you guys leave three
things you're grateful for in the live
chat and for those are you watching
afterwards leave in the comments below
do it don't just lurk don't just watch
leave it take action and the second part
is that you actually have to feel it ask
yourself why when you're talking about
whatever you're grateful for don't just
list it off think about why I feel it
for a couple seconds so that you
experience the emotional benefit if
you're not feeling the emotional benefit
you're not going to get the game so
happy thursday i'm going to go first and
then see what you guys have to say in
the live check I'm super grateful for
the day that's ahead today is the
busiest possible livestream day that I
have open in my calendar I have nine
live streams happening today it's
basically going from one to the other to
the other there's this then the League
of Legends business QA right after and
then I've got seven hangouts later today
talking from the YouTube algorithm
packing it to grant cardone coming on
talking about how to be obsessed to
social media apps all over the place
and I'm just super grateful to have all
of these experts at my fingertips to
really come on and share knowledge so I
learn as well as you guys learn the
process right anybody I want to learn
from I can have on the show and I get to
ask selfish questions for myself and as
well as benefit you guys so I'm really
grateful for the opportunity and then
really excited for for the day ahead uh
I'm grateful for my blue jays eyeball
where's the cap i got to be any beneath
the playoff hat i'm excited for my blue
jays we have game one of our playoff
series with texas sorry for all you
Texas fans but I'm rootin for Toronto
today that starts at four thirty eastern
my last hangout starts at four fifteen
Eastern so I'm going to miss a little
bit of the game but go right into that
after I you know just grateful to have a
team to cheer for it's great to see the
energy the city is all alive everybody's
buzzing and talking and I'm pumped and
excited I'm just good for that energetic
feeling and looking forward to what
happens tonight and then the third thing
for me would be some of the people on my
team at a Toronto dense also i had a
great meeting last night with one of our
helpers and helpers are more advanced
students that contribute back and
volunteered at the school to help
students who are at a lower level than
them and this guy's been with us for a
number of years and just has a lot of
love for the business wants to see the
company succeed do better reach more
students pretty selfless and and amazing
you know when you stand for something
important when you're having a real
impact then people will line up to try
to help you and just super grateful and
fortunate to have a lot of those kinds
of people in both my businesses really
and we wouldn't be anywhere near what we
are without the support of all those
people who've helped us out
those are mine all the live streams
today the Blue Jays and the amazing
people in my businesses let's get to
what you guys are grateful for in the
live chat first up Zeno Xena was back
the return of the body part of the day I
love it Zeno Zeno is grateful for my
teeth for allowing me to eat more than
just soup other liquid or super soft
food or just really tiny bites I love it
I'm good for my teeth too man number two
the location of my house because pretty
much everything I need is nearby I feel
you one of the reasons why I'm in my
condo here in the intersection that I'm
at in in city Toronto is there's so much
around I want to be able to walk the
stuff I want to be able to walk to
restaurants movies you know just people
i like i like a city vibe so I'm feel
you there a number three doctors nurses
firemen and yes even policemen for
keeping us safe and alive I wonder what
the caveat there is on the policemen
whether they even police him but I met I
love it I love it what do we have what
do we have j rise in the house thankful
for good thankful that good things
continually flow to me and through me
for imagination where all things start
and four bathrooms because they're
awesome bathrooms are awesome thank you
j reyez maha villas back what's up hey
meribella welcome back and I just did my
scroll gotta love YouTube alright next
Rishi I'm beautiful for another day I'm
grateful from my kneecaps rishis doing
the xeno body part of the day to know
I'm hopeful for delicious food hashtag
cup of morning y'all welcome Rishi what
else what else what else we got m'ville
was waiting for my crazy clapping you
know what is a good experiment I did
that so yes he was my filming day for my
youtube channel and I did that before
each video that I recorded and so we'll
see if you see some extra fire coming
out of the YouTube videos in the next
next week
saturday-sunday I film almost a week
ahead then it'll be from the clapping I
like the clapping too I did it I did it
once on the live stream on the day that
I was going to go do my audio book
because I was so fired up and excited
and I thought that was a great leading I
got me extra fire it up so you know what
I gotta do it I'll do it each time so
it's a fun little experiment and they'll
see how it goes what else what else John
Emerson good morning believe nation
welcome John Caesar Clark morning y'all
happy I made it happy to have you here
to Caesar sky's the limit good day
everyone Ben pitcher food water and air
super important arrest date hello
everyone welcome catalina good morning
and said Suraj hello Evan your voice
sounds like you're on the mend yes get
in there I might lose it today with all
the hangouts but I'm getting there
Nessie yeah I'm truly people for you
Evan I'm truly grateful and excited
about my life I'm grateful for change I
appreciate that and I love the change a
lot of people are not grateful for
change and fight it so I love it dude
I'm grateful to be watching this video
welcome to que el bien buenos dias a
todos welcome que el feki nom hello
jagdeep hi Shiva I love your videos
thank you Jimmy thank you for an awesome
thank you for an awesome job my family
and life in general 11 Jamie thanks for
sharing send Pablo thanks for the Nipsey
Hussle top 10 video nipsey's Nipsey you
guys haven't seen it it's a pretty
quality video uh he drops a lot of
knowledge in there it's worth it's worth
checking out Carlos morning today I'm
grateful for the opportunity for growth
and betterment I love it Catalina
grateful for my daughter which she is
very sweet with me I love it Sheba very
emotional get emotional John life
partnerships my fight november
seventeenth finally made it good luck at
the fight man cheering you on let's see
what the live stream is we could cheer
from our computers
jon john jon john jon john good morning
everyone much is back LOL Nessie you
rock Kevin hashtag mentorship phenom I'm
grateful for being up early today hey
we're glad you could join us up early
today too what else what else que el
bien I'm so grateful for my phone
because of the pen so much of it in
order to succeed much I'm grateful for a
really nice night of sleep I love sleep
what else what else what else kayle
kayle crosman much i feel you i'm people
for a great night's sleep as well all
right k i'll be on a grateful for family
guy because that show has made me laugh
for so many years i love it what else
what else what else you guys got Sarah
good morning good for my car you look
for my clients google for oolong and
white tee and all my Chinese collection
LOL i love it well guys it's nine ten
that's how we're gonna end it off thank
you Sarah we're going to hop on to the
twitch stream for the business QA while
I play league of legends with Jay rise
and Rishi cup TV if this is the last
time I see you today go crush it have an
amazing day if not I'll see you guys on
the hangouts all day long for some
believe love thank you guys for watching
you need to believe or whatever your one
word is and I'll see you soon